NOW.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
>>> NEW THIS MORNING, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW TAKING AIM
AT TWO FORMER REPUBLICAN ALLIES
IN THE U.S. SENATE WHO REFUSE TO
BACK THE BIG LIE, ACCORDING TO A
NEW BOOK.
BOB WOODWARD AND ROBERT COSTA
WRITE IN THE BOOK "PERIL" THAT
SENATORS MIKE LEE AND LINDSEY
GRAHAM INVESTIGATED TRUMP'S
CLAIMS OF FRAUD IN THE 2020
ELECTION, AND FOUND THEY ADDED
UP TO NOTHING.
HERE'S PART OF A NEW STATEMENT
FROM TRUMP, IT SAYS, I SPENT
VIRTUALLY NO TIME WITH SENATORS
MIKE LEE OF UTAH OR LINDSEY
GRAHAM OF SOUTH CAROLINA TALKING
ABOUT THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION SCAM OR AS IT IS VIEWED
BY MANY, THE CRIME OF THE
CENTURY.
LINDSEY AND MIKE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES FOR NOT
PUTTING UP THE FIGHT NECESSARY
TO WIN.
JOINING US NOW WE HAVE CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR ANA
NAVARRO TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
ANA, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT HE'S SAYING, THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES?
>> YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
REVELATIONS, BUT THEY'RE NOT
REVELATIONS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S
CHARACTER.
IT IS VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE
DONALD TRUMP THAT WE GOT TO KNOW
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
AND SO NO MATTER HOW LOYAL
PEOPLE LIKE LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
MIKE LEE WERE TO HIM, FOR YEARS
THEY WERE HIS ACOLYTES, HIS
RUBBER STAMPS ON SO MANY ISSUES,
THEY WERE BY HIS SIDE, LINDSEY
GRAHAM WAS PRACTICALLY HIS MINI
ME, A SYMBIOTIC TWIN, REGARDLESS
OF THAT, THE MINUTE THEY TURN ON
HIM, THE MINUTE THEY'RE NOT
WILLING TO CROSS A BRIDGE THAT
IS A BRIDGE TOO FAR BECAUSE IT
IS ABOUT DESTROYING DEMOCRACY
AND BASED ON LIES, THEN THEY'RE
NOT LOYAL.
THEN HE TURNS ON THEM AND HE
TURNS ALL THE CANNONS ON THEM.
I THINK IT EXPLAINS SOME OF
LINDSEY'S -- SOME OF LINDSEY'S
ACTIONS AFTER THE ELECTION WHEN
WE SAW HIM QUICKLY TRY IT GO TO
MAR-A-LAGO AND TRY TO MAKE UP
WITH HIM.
BUT IT IS JUST -- IT IS CRAZY.
IT IS NEVER ENOUGH FOR TRUMP.
BECAUSE IT IS ALWAYS ABOUT ONE
THING, DONALD TRUMP.
>> I'M SURE LINDSEY GRAHAM IS
GOING TO QUIT DONALD TRUMP NOW,
ANA, RIGHT?
>> HOLD YOUR BREATH, WHY DON'T
YOU?
I'LL BRING OVER AN OXYGEN TANK.
>> SERIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, WHY --
IT IS JUST ANOTHER THING WHERE
LINDSEY GRAHAM COULD NOT
POSSIBLY DO MORE TO CURRY FAVOR
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
YES, HE SAID COUNT ME OUT ON
JANUARY 7th OR WHATEVER IT WAS,
BUT HE DIDN'T MEAN IT.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T COUNT HIM
OUT, HE'S PLAYING GOLF WITH
DONALD TRUMP TALKING TO HIM
WHENEVER HE CAN AND TRUMP
CRITICIZING HIM TODAY FOR WHAT'S
IN THE BOOK, BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE
THIS IS GOING TO KEEP LINDSEY
GRAHAM FROM GOING TO PLAY GOLF
TOMORROW.
>> I CAN'T EITHER.
I THINK THERE IS NOT ENOUGH TIME
IN THIS PROGRAM TO PSYCHOANALYZE
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND HIS NEED FOR
A PEDRINO, BIG BROTHER TO BE
SOMEBODY'S SIDEKICK WHETHER IT
IS JOHN McCAIN OR DONALD TRUMP.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU, ANA, ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE SEEING AT THE BORDER
AND HOW, FOR INSTANCE, FOX AND
SOME IN THE GOP, MANY IN THE GOP
ARE RESPONDING TO IT.
THERE SEEMS TO BE AN INCREASE IN
TALKING ABOUT THAT THIS IS
REPLACEMENT THEORY, THAT THIS IS
MIGRANTS COMING IN, ESSENTIALLY
TO BENEFIT DEMOCRATS.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THE ONLY CONCLUSION ANY
RATIONAL PERSON CAN REACH IS
THIS IS DELIBERATE, THIS IS
INTENTIONAL, THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGNED
ON IN 2016 WHEN SHE TALKED ABOUT
A BORDERLESS HEMISPHERE.
>> NOTHING ABOUT IT IS AN
ACCIDENT, OBVIOUSLY.
IT IS INTENTIONAL.
JOE BIDEN DID IT ON PURPOSE.
THIS POLICY IS CALLED THE GREAT
REPLACEMENT, THE REPLACEMENT OF
LEGACY, AMERICANS WITH MORE
OBEDIENT PEOPLE FROM FAR AWAY
COUNTRIES.
>> I MEAN, ANA.
>> MM.
LOOK, THE ONE THING I AGREE WITH
IS THAT VERY LITTLE OF THIS IS
ACCIDENTAL.
I THINK IT'S -- I THINK IT'S
VERY SUSPICIOUS AND IT IS VERY
REMINISCENT OF THE CARAVAN THAT
HAPPENED RIGHT BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS, WHICH IS AN
IMMIGRATION ISSUE THAT WAS --
THAT HAPPENED, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SHOWING UP
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND IT IS
USED TO ENFLAME THE POLITICAL
PASSIONS.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICUL NUT FOR
JOSEPH BIDEN TO CRACK.
HE HAS ISSUS WITH HIS OWN PARTY
WHO ARE CRITICAL AND ATTACKING
HIM FOR NOT BEING WELCOMING
ENOUGH.
AND THEN A HUGE ISSUE AND
BECOMING ONE THAT FRANKLY
ENFLAMES RACISTS AND DIVISION
AND US VERSUS THEN AND INVASION
AND INVADERS AND ALIEN, YOU
KNOW, PROTOTYPES AND STEREOTYPES
AND WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
LOOK, THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
THAT THIS IS TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE FLEEING POLITICAL
STRIFE, FLEEING POVERTY, FLEEING
POLITICAL CORRUPTION.
I THINK THERE IS MANY QUESTIONS
TO BE ASKED AS TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
I THINK -- I THINK WE HAVE NOT
SEEN ALL THE FACTS HERE.
THIS IS A -- THIS SITUATION, I
THINK, HAS MANY MORE LAYERS TO
THE ONION THAN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
AS OF YET.
>> AND, LOOK, YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
ISSUES AT THE BORDER AND CLEAR
PROBLEM WITH AN INFLUX OF
MIGRANTS, BUT REPLACEMENT THEORY
ISN'T EVEN THINLY VEILED RACISM.
YOU HEARD TUCKER CARLSON SAY,
REPLACE -- WHAT IS A LEGACY
AMERICAN?
IT RHYMES WITH WHITE, ANA.
SO HE'S SAYING THAT LEGACY --
WHITE PEOPLE ARE BEING REPLACED.
>> WHICH IS SUCH A BASTION,
RIGHT, SUCH A PILLAR FOR THE
FOUNDATION OF DONALD TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN.
MAKE WHITE PEOPLE FEEL ANGER.
SEW DIVISION WITHIN AMERICANS.
MAKE IT SO THAT YOU ARE FEEDING
INTO THIS IDEA THAT BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER AND REPLACING US.
THINK ABOUT JEWS WILL NOT
REPLACE US IN CHARLOTTESVILLE.
THINK ABOUT ALL THESE THINGS,
THE MANIFESTO OF THE MAN WHO
WENT TO THE WALMART AND SHOT
OVER 20 LATINOS, HUNTED THEM
DOWN IN EL PASO, TEXAS.
THINK OF ALL THOSE THINGS AND
JUST HOW, YOU KNOW, IT WAS ABOUT
DIVIDE AND CONQUER.
AND I THINK THAT THEY SAW THAT A
WINNING STRATEGY, MAKING WHITE
PEOPLE FEEL ANGRY, FEEL
DISTRESSED, FEEL PASSIONATELY
OKAY TO BE RACIST.
BUT, YOU KNOW, SO THIS IS
CONFLATING THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE
WITH RACISM.
IF IT WAS 20,000 NORWEGIANS IN
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, WOULD
TUCKER CARLSON BE SAYING THE
SAME THING?
IT HAPPENS TO BE 20,000 BLACK
HAITIANS AND CENTRAL AMERICANS.
AND IF HE THINKS THAT HAITIANS
AND CENTRAL AMERICANS ARE MORE
OBEDIENT, I WAS BORN IN
NICARAGUA, I SUGGEST ONE DAY HE
LEAVE HIS LITTLE BUBBLE IN HIS
STUDIO AND GET OUT OF THIS
COUNTRY AND GO SEE WHAT
PEOPLE -- LET'S REMEMBER THAT
HAITI WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
REPUBLICS IN THE HEMISPHERE THAT
DECLARED ITS INDEPENDENCE, THAT
IT WAS SLAVES REBELLING IN HAITI
THAT MADE IT ONE OF THE FIRST
INDEPENDENT COUNTRIES IN THE
HEMISPHERE.
>> NO INDICATION THAT HE KNOWS
THAT OR WOULD CERTAINLY SHARE
THAT WITH HIS AUDIENCE.
I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING HAPPENING IN YOUR HOME
STATE, WHICH IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR, PUTTING IN PLACE THIS
SURGEON GENERAL WHO IS, LOOK, IF
YOU LOOK AT HIS -- IF YOU LOOK
AT HIS RESUME ON PAPER, YOU
KNOW, HARVARD, Ph.D. LOOKS
PRETTY GOOD.
BUT ONCE YOU LOOK INTO WHAT HE
HAS TALKED ABOUT, HE'S
ANTI-MASK, HE'S VACCINE
SKEPTICAL, HE'S APPEARED AT
THESE AMERICA FRONT LINE DOCTOR
EVENTS WITH, FOR INSTANCE, THE
DEMON SPERM DOCTOR WHO CLEARLY
HAS PROBLEMS WITH FACTS, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS?
>> I THINK RON DeSANTIS FOUND A
GUY WHO IS RON DeSANTIS, BUT
WITH A MEDICAL DEGREE.
LISTEN, RON DeSANTIS IS A GUY
WHO IS ALSO A HARVARD AND YALE
GRAD.
AND THE GUY WE'RE SEEING NOW IN
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS IS
THE DIFFERENT THAN THE GUY WHO
WAS FIRST ELECTED.
RON DeSANTIS GOT ELECTED BY A
VERY SLIM MARGIN.
THERE WAS A RECOUNT IN FLORIDA.
THERE IS ALWAYS A RECOUNT IN
FLORIDA, BUT -- AND HE CAME IN
TALKING ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
HE CAME IN TRYING TO BE
CONCILIATORY.
BUT HE'S OBVIOUSLY DECIDED HE
WANTS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT, THAT
HE WANTS THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION, AND THAT THE WAY TO
DO IT IS TO CATER TO THE
REPUBLICAN DONALD TRUMP BASE AND
THAT MEANS THE FOLKS WHO EMBRACE
ANTI-SCIENCE, WHO DENY VACCINES,
WHO BELIEVE IN, YOU KNOW, CATTLE
DEWORMERS, WHO -- WE SEE HIM
OVER AND OVER TAKING THIS AS A
CRUSADE, RIGHT?
WHETHER IT IS SUING SCHOOL
BOARDS, WHETHER IT IS TELLING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT HE'S
GOING TO FIND THEM IF THEY ISSUE
A MASK MANDATE, AND NOW WITH HIS
PICK FOR SURGEON GENERAL.
LOOK, YOU KNOW, THE BOTTOM LINE
IS AS A FLORIDIAN, AS SOMEBODY
WHO LIVES IN FLORIDA, AND WHOSE
LIFE IS DIRECTLY IMPACTED AND
AFFECTED BY THIS, THE NUMBERS OF
DEATHS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS WE
HAVE SEEN OUT OF FLORIDA, AND
OUT OF THE STATE THAT ARE NOT
VACCINATED, ARE GRUESOME, ARE
SCARY, ARE PAINFUL.
THOSE ARE REAL PEOPLE.
SO PUTTING POLITICS OVER
PEOPLE'S LIVES REALLY